good morning my name is Chuck Collins
and I am the co-founder of responsible
wealth I want to welcome you here to
this press conference a discussion about
issues related to the federal estate tax
responsible wealth is a national
organization of 800 business leaders
high net worth individuals who are
concerned about the growing polarization
of income and wealth in the United
States and have been very outspoken in
support of public policies that
encourage shared prosperity and reduce
inequality obviously the main tax
related issue this week is the debate
over the different stimulus packages and
we are here to say that that's an
important discussion but we also think
we should not take our eye off the ball
of the federal estate tax the federal
estate tax is an issue that is going to
come up this spring there's going to be
probably be a vote to make the estate
tax permanent and we know that the
battle over the estate tax will become
back in the news again and we're here to
sort of lay the groundwork for that
discussion without any action the
federal estate tax will be repealed in
the year 2010 and then we'll come back
in the year 2011 and that is one of the
reasons why making the repeal of the
federal estate tax permanent is a major
priority of the President and many
members of Congress they will be working
very hard to make permanent the repeal
let us also not forget that millions of
dollars was poured into Senate races in
states like Minnesota and South Dakota
Missouri to attack sitting senators for
their position in opposition to a state
tax repeal so we believe this is a very
important issue
we are also here to announce today that
we are launching a proactive campaign to
ring reinvigorate the public debate
about the estate tax issue the
proponents of wholesale repeal have had
almost a ten year head start in terms of
shaping the language and lining up votes
and spinning the message and we're here
to say we're going to make a very
affirmative effort to get the
information out there about the estate
tax what are the prospects for reform
and who does it really affect one of the
pieces of that is going to be a reform
proposal and we have one of the leading
proponents of that reform initiative
here to speak to you today we are
advocates of mending the estate tax but
not ending it reforming it but not
eliminating it the other part of this
effort is in terms of education and
we're pleased to announce that this
Thursday beacon press will be publishing
a book authored by mr. gates senior and
myself called wealth and our
Commonwealth why America should tax
accumulated fortunes and this is an
effort to make a historical and
practical argument about why we should
preserve some estate tax on enormous
fortunes in the United States our three
speakers today each speak to one of the
main reasons why we believe the estate
tax should be preserved first the estate
tax is a fair and progressive source of
revenue to pay for government and
especially at a time of state and fiscal
budget disasters it is an important part
of how we raise revenue second the
estate tax is a stimulus for charitable
giving it is a catalyst primarily for
the very wealthy households households
with 20 million dollars and up and it
encourages families that are charitably
in oriented to give more money to
hospitals to civic organizations to
universities and to create foundations
and the third reason is that the estate
tax is healthy for our democracy it
helps interrupt the build-up of
concentrations of wealth dynasties in
the
united states and as Louis Brandeis said
you can have concentrations of wealth in
the hands of a few or you can have
democracy but you cannot have both and
so at one of the reasons why we're
concerned about losing entirely a
federal estate tax is the impact that
would have on our democracy and society
before I introduce senator Kent Conrad I
want to introduce bill gayle of the
Brookings Institution who is here with
us and bill is an economist and an
expert on issues in relation to these
state tax and we cut may call upon him
around some very technical questions he
speaks for himself and does not
represent the views of the Brookings
Institution I also want to introduce
Gary bass who is the chairman of
Americans for a fair estate tax which is
a national coalition of charities
nonprofits and other civic groups who
are affected by the estate tax you might
have the might have the impression that
that only responsible wealth and very
wealthy individuals are opposed to
repeal of the estate tax but in fact
there's a very broad-based effort that
includes the National Farmers Union and
arts organizations and ordinary men and
women in the united states senator Kent
Conrad has represented the people of
North Dakota in the US Senate since 1986
he is that he is the at this moment he's
the chairman of the senate budget
committee until the committee is
reorganized I don't know if you have any
statements in that regard but the the
but senator Conrad one of the reasons
he's here is he has been the voice of
reason and responsibility on matters of
the federal budget he has been a leader
on the issue of estate tax reform and
for several years has introduced reform
proposals we've asked senator Conrad to
set the context in terms of the federal
budget as well as discusses views on a
state tax reform please welcome senator
Kent Conrad Thank You Chuck good morning
it's good to be with you I am senator
Kent Conrad represent the state of North
Dakota in the United States Senate and
serve on the Budget Committee and on the
Finance Committee where I have
responsibility for trying to solve the
fiscal crisis now facing the country and
I think crisis is the appropriate term
when we look at where we are and where
we're headed the first chart that I've
put up shows what we thought we faced
just two years ago when we were told by
the president when we were told by the
Congressional Budget Office that we
could anticipate five point six trillion
dollars of surpluses over the next
decade what a difference a year makes
now in 2003 we see that if the
president's proposals are adopted for
that same period instead of nearly six
trillion dollars of surpluses were
nearly two trillion dollars in the red
that is a swing of over seven trillion
dollars in the space of about 18 months
that is the most dramatic swing in the
fiscal fortunes of this nation in our
history and it has significant
implications let's go to the next chart
this chart shows two possible scenarios
one is looking ahead and adopting just
what has occurred so far in terms of
budget changes the tax cuts already
enacted the spending changes already
enacted to respond to September 11th
that is the increased spending for
defense and Homeland Security and that's
the top dotted line showing that almost
through the rest of the decade we are
going to be in the red that is if you
don't use social security to pay for
other things if you don't use social
security to cover the cost of the tax
cuts if you don't use Social Security
funds to cover other spending you can
see that we are in deficit almost the
entire rest of the decade and the second
dotted line the bottom dotted line shows
what happens if we adopt the additional
proposals put forward by the president
make permanent the tax cuts already
enacted and number to adopt the stimulus
package that he has proposed you can see
if that policy is followed we will never
escape from a deficit position the
entire rest of the decade why is that
significant and important well it's
critically important because this is an
unusual decade this is a decade unlike
any we have ever seen before because of
the baby boom generation the baby boom
generation changes everything because
they are poised to retire starting at
the end of this decade and this will
create a dynamic unlike anything we've
ever seen before I think this is a
critically important point to make and
to have understood always before we had
time to get well this time there is no
time to get well and this is not a
matter of a projection the baby boomers
are born they're living today they are
eligible for Medicare and Social
Security and they are going to change
everything let's go to the third chart
that shows that you can see that we are
right now in the sweet spot of the cycle
that is these reserve funds these trust
funds of Social Security and Medicare
are right now running substantial
surpluses very large surpluses that are
currently being used under the
president's plan to pay for his tax cuts
and the defense buildup and the
increased spending for homeland security
but in 2016 you can see that the
Medicare trust fund goes cash- and in
2017 the Social Security trust fund goes
cash- and when they do they do it in a
very precipitous way in other words they
start with mild cash negative balances
but they grow very quickly and very
dramatically in a negative direction
this is what we must prepare
for this is why it is so critically
important that our citizens understand
and our colleagues understand the
choices that are before us now because
these are choices they're going to make
a profound difference in the years ahead
let me go to the next slide which quotes
the current director of the
Congressional Budget Office in testimony
before the Senate Budget Committee when
he said in response to a question that I
directed to him put more starkly mr.
chairman the extremes of what will be
required to address our retirement are
these will have to increase borrowing by
very large likely unsustainable amounts
raise taxes to thirty percent of gross
domestic product obviously unprecedented
in our history or eliminate most of the
rest of government as we know it that's
the dilemma that faces us in the long
run mr. chairman and these next 10 years
will only be the beginning and the
reason he said it's only the beginning
is because of the previous chart that
shows you we're in the sweet spot of the
cycle now and instead of getting ready
for what's to come we're frittering the
opportunity we're frittering it away we
instead of using these surpluses to
prepare for what's to come are spending
them spending them for tax cuts spending
them for other expenses of government
now in the midst of this harsh reality
the president says to us we ought to
make the tax cuts permanent we ought to
even add to them with a stimulus package
which has a very substantial 10-year
cost and part of making the taxes tax
cuts previously previously passed
permanent is to eliminate the estate tax
you can see the cost in this decade is
close to a hundred billion dollars but
the cost in the next decade right at the
time the baby boom generation is
tiring and the costs as I've shown you
on previous charts are escalating and
the deficits exploding so does the drain
of federal revenue as a result of
elimination of the estate tax the costs
as I've indicated this decade nearly a
hundred billion dollars but in the next
decade the cost is seven hundred and
forty billion dollars again right at the
time the baby boom generation retires
now the argument has been advanced that
the estate tax is really immoral because
these revenues these assets have already
been taxed once and so it constitutes
double taxation in a study done by mr.
Peter ba and mr. Weiss better mr. Peter
Baba of MIT mr. Weiss benner of the
University of Illinois both doing work
for the Brookings Institution they point
out that that is simply a myth on
estates of over ten million dollars
fully fifty-six percent of those assets
have never been taxed have never been
taxed because they're unrealized capital
gains that have never been subjected to
taxation so this notion that this is all
double taxation is largely a myth
certainly some part of these assets have
been previously subjected to taxation
but that is true throughout our tax
system we tax payroll taxes that applies
to the same income as our as is applied
to income taxes and of course we have
sales taxes after people have paid
income taxes on received income so
double taxation if that were to be
eliminated in our society throughout the
structure the tax structure we would
have deficits that were totally
unsustainable let me go to the next
point which is we are currently on
course to dramatically reduce the number
of S state subject to taxation
as many of you know currently only two
percent of s states pay any estate tax
the notion there is a death tax is
simply a Miss known misnomer there's no
death tax we have no levy that applies
to everyone at death we have an estate
tax that applies to estates currently
for an individual of over 1 million
dollars so if you have less than 1
million dollars of assets or if you're a
couple less than two million dollars of
assets you pay no tax zero there is no
death tax there is an estate tax that
attaches to larger accumulations of
wealth and we're currently on course to
increase that amount to three and a half
million dollars by 2009 and that's for
an individual that would be seven
million dollars for a couple and that
will mean 99.7 percent of s states are
not subject to any taxation at all the
point has been made that many of us
support reform over repeal that's
because we see this is a question of
choices in a perfect world we wouldn't
have any taxes that that would be a
state I think we'd all enjoy but we
understand there are trade-offs there
are things that are needed certainly we
have to provide for our common defense
we have to improve Homeland Security we
need to improve the education of our
children expand health care coverage
provide a prescription drug benefit
protect and preserve Social Security and
Medicare those things cost money what is
abundantly clear is we do not have the
resources under the current tax
structure to do those things and in fact
we are headed for a crisis in Social
Security and Medicare and Social
Security we're only going to be able to
over 75 percent of the future costs so
there is a giant chasm between what is
been promised the American people and
what can be delivered to the American
people and the question is how you going
to fill in that gap the president and
those who advocate the elimination of
the estate tax are digging the hole
deeper some of us say yes there needs to
be reformed we should increase the
amount that is exempt from s state tax I
proposed last year an immediate increase
from a million dollars of exemption for
an individual to 3 million for a couple
that would mean six million dollars
completely exempt and the cost is as
this chart shows dramatically less than
an elimination of the estate tax instead
of a 10-year cost of nearly a hundred
billion dollars that reform would cost
twelve point six billion dollars and
leave more money available to protect
Social Security to preserve Medicare to
improve education to expand health care
and to strengthen our national defense
and improve our homeland security at the
bottom that's what this issue is all
about it is a question of choices and
the American people and my colleagues
their representatives are going to have
to make these difficult choices I think
it's critically important that we
understand the context within which we
make them the reality has changed as the
first chart i showed demonstrated two
years ago we thought we had massive
surpluses for the rest of the decade now
what we see instead of surpluses is
deficits and at the same time we see an
increased need for spending on defense
and homeland security the president and
many of us advocate additional costs for
a prescription drug benefit and there
are other costs as well that we will
have to face the question is how we do
it
some of us would suggest that a tax on
wealth is one reasonable way to meet
part of these needs it's going to take
much more than that to solve these
problems and if instead we choose the
course of eliminating the estate tax
helping just those who are at the very
top what that means is all the rest of
us are going to have to pay more this is
not really a question of eliminating the
inheritance tax those who advocate
repeal are in effect creating a whole
new tax burden because this debt will
have to be serviced and if part of it is
not taken by those with great
accumulations of wealth many of whose
assets have never been taxed that means
the rest of us are going to have to pay
more more in income tax more in payroll
tax more in a state on some other
perhaps form of a state tax more in
every other kind of levy because the
real inheritance will be an inheritance
of debt debt passed on to our children
that we were unwilling to bear ourselves
even though it was our generation that
ran up the debt reform yes repeal no it
is simply not affordable in the reality
of today the reality created after
September 11th by a sneak attack on this
country that is dramatically increased
defense costs increased homeland
security costs and coupled with the
president's tax cuts plunged us deep
into deficits and debt deficits and debt
that are growing at such a rate that
they are clearly unsustainable so my
conclusion is reform yes repeal no and I
am pleased to be joined today by two of
the foremost
people who have been advocates on this
issue for a number of years I look
forward to hearing from them thank you
very much Thank You senator Conrad mr.
George Soros is the chairman of soros
fund management and has been a leading
philanthropists since 1979 he was one of
the early defenders of the estate tax in
the summer of 2000 mr. Soros wrote in
the pages of the Wall Street Journal
that quote abolishing the estate tax
would remove one of the main incentives
for charitable giving college presidents
and directors of cultural and charitable
organizations ought to be out in force
lobbying against it mr. Soros thank you
thank you very much I think senator
Conrad made a very convincing case that
repealing the estate tax would impose an
inheritance tax on all our children the
estate tax effects 0.3% 0.7 percent i
think or three percent of the number of
people whereas the inheritance tax that
the repeal would impose on future
generations with affect us all taxation
like death is a unpleasant reality you
can't abolish either death or taxation
it's all a question of how do you tax
and when it comes to that question I
have always felt that the estate tax is
actually the least damaging of all our
taxations because it does not interfere
with wealth creation it increases social
equality and also it encourages
charitable donations which have become a
very important element of our society
under the influence of the estate tax
actually I'm quite struck by the
difference between the United States and
you
where there is much less of a tradition
and much less scope of a charitable
giver giving them there is in the in the
united states and why does it interfere
least with wealth creation because it
taxes the creator of wealth after he
passes of when he passes away so it will
certainly not diminish his incentives to
create wealth while he is alive and his
children are not particularly well
qualified to create additional wealth
I'm often asked you know do you feel did
you set up your foundations because you
feel guilty about of the amount of money
you have made and I I can only reply I
don't feel guilty at all I feel proud of
the amount of money that I have made but
my children would be in a different
position being members of the lucky
sperm Club that doesn't necessarily give
them any sense of pride or
accomplishment so I don't think that I'm
doing my children any favors by passing
on a large amount of wealth to them so
that it's really the point at which the
the taxation interferes the least with
productive economic activity we also now
live in a society where the difference
between the the the gap between the rich
and poor is getting wider which is not a
healthy thing for society and repealing
the estate tax would reinforce
this this threat this development this
trend now to include the repeal of the
estate tax in the stimulus package is
really such nonsense that I'm at a loss
to do how to how to speak about it I
mean it has absolutely nothing to do
with economic stimulus on the contrary
as Senator Conrad has explained the
increase of the deficit will interfere
with economic recovery right now when
the economy is depressed it doesn't have
any effect on interest rates but the
moment the economy recovers as a market
participant I can assure you that
interest rates are going to long-term
interest rates are going to rise very
substantially interfering with the way
to recovery so as a it's very difficult
for me to keep on arguing because I feel
that this is so counterproductive that
as I say I am at a loss for words thank
you
Thank You mr. Soros you remind me of a
hundred years ago when Andrew Carnegie
stood up to defend or advocate for the
creation of an inheritance tax and
estate tax and he talked about not only
the inequalities of the Gilded Age but
also the impact on his children as well
and and and therefore advocating for the
creation of an inheritance tax mr. Bill
Gates senior is in his day job the
co-chairman of the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation which among other
things is a leading philanthropic
organization on world health issues two
years ago as the effort to repeal the
estate tax was gathering momentum mr.
gates joined up with responsible wealth
to put forward one of the more visible
defenses of the estate tax and in doing
so I think it caused a lot of people to
re-examine the arguments for all or
nothing elimination of the estate tax
there are now 1,100 individuals who
signed the petition called a call to
preserve the estate tax who would have
to have paid the estate tax so at
responsible wealth org on a website of
1,100 people who would have to pay have
signed to say don't eliminate and many
more are signing on every day in the
process of that debate last year or two
years ago mr. gates I think really
contributed to the robustness of the
debate about the estate tax some of the
questions that he raised and answered
include what kind of nation do we want
to become as we grow more unequal what
is it worth to be an American and what
is the responsibility of wealthy
individuals and what claim to society
have upon them mr. gates has co-authored
a book wealth and our Commonwealth which
will be coming out on Thursday and he's
about to begin a nine city speaking tour
and book to her
it's not an ordinary book tour there are
going to be dozens of events that are
bringing together galvanizing people
charity organizations nonprofit groups
farm organizations to come together and
talk about building this movement for
reform and not repeal and building a
fairer estate tax so please welcome mr.
gates
mmm
senator Conrad has done a wonderful job
of summarizing the the several and
actually unimpeachable reasons why the
estate tax needs to be preserved let me
just focus on one feature of this
argument we start with the proposition
that this is the tax which is imposed on
very very few Americans and I think that
it's that's so badly misunderstood
there's a almost a populist feeling that
nobody wants to pay taxes when they die
when in fact it is such a small
percentage of our citizens who are
exposed to this tax and as exemptions
increase that percentage goes down and
down as the the Senators chart showed we
get down to a number of Americans which
is less less than 1% of us now it one
can ask a question about well is that is
that a good way to go what what kind of
attacks is that that would only applies
to two percent or one percent or three
tenths of one percent of the people in
this country does that make any sense
and it does make sense we know we in
this country for years I think the
majority view has been supportive of the
notion of progressive taxation the
estate tax is the most progressive
element of a progressive tax system
absolutely the most progressive element
what is the justification for that many
of you have been approached by your old
friends from college who are raising
money for the school and saying now Joe
you went to good old siwash you and it
was time for you you've made some money
time for you to make a gift back to that
University you oh it's something and you
know there's a great there's a great
sentiment in this country of support for
that for that argument for that notion
things which have benefited you which
have made it possible for you to be
wealthy are owed something for their
contribution for your success for your
comfort why is it that some people are
so wealthy they're smart probably they
work hard they were perhaps even
ingenious but let's just ask ourselves
if they had been born in Botswana what
would their net worth be and what's the
difference the difference is that
they're Americans they're born in a
country that has an army and a navy that
protects them they're born in a country
which has an orderly market if you get
up on Thursday you know that the rules
are the same as they were the day before
in this country there's a police force
there's a court system there is all the
infrastructure that makes it possible to
run a robust economy and there is an
element of this society of ours an
element provided totally by government
which is overlooked in this argument and
it shouldn't be where does this economy
come what is the robust robustness of
this world in which we live in this fine
country the robustness comes from
innovation which comes from research do
you know there would not be an internet
but for federal taxation do you know
that there would not be by a techno
technology chol progress there would be
no businesses based on the human genome
if it weren't for federal taxation
people who have become wealthy people
whose businesses prosper in this country
have become wealthy because of the
contribution made the contribution made
by government service which occurs
because we do pay our tax
I i I've invented a fable to illustrate
this I assume that up in heaven God
unfortunately put an inordinate amount
of his net worth into the dot-com stocks
and his his his Treasury is badly
depleted and he's worried about what to
do to deal with this and an idea comes
to him and in order to put that idea
into place he calls before him the two
spirits of the next babies to be born in
this world and he says to them you know
I have this financial problem and I've
decided I know how to solve it it just
happens that today you two are the next
two human beings to be born and I have
one spot in the United States and
another spot somewhere else and I'm
going to auction off that spot in the
United States and I'm going to hand you
each a piece of paper and write down on
that piece of paper what part of your
net worth you're willing to cede back to
my Treasury on the day you die what part
of your net worth would you yield on
your death to be born in America now do
you think either of those spirits would
write down a number less than one
hundred percent not a chance what is it
worth to be an American that's what
we're arguing about that's why the
estate tax makes so much sense thank
like to welcome your questions from
journalists only if you could please
state your name and identify your news
organization speak as loudly as you can
and address a question to a speaker yes
sir mr. Soros mr. gates abs we've got a
substantial amount of money you identify
yourself and your I'm with congressional
quarterly my name is Alan ocha thank you
well you would you be willing to put up
and do you plan to spend much of your
money to in any sort of campaign to you
know develop media or advertising to to
make this point that you're you know
trying to prevent the repeal of the
estate tax and converse I wonder how
much of a factor do you think it is that
wealthy people perhaps its heirs of
wealthy families are supporting the
repeal of the estate tax you think that
is played a role in the success of their
argument why do I think rich people
think there should be no as they know
what do you think they didn't know
effective in in winning this argument so
far and what do you plan to the reason
for that is that they have been out
working on the American public and
members of Congress for about 10 years
and they put it in an especially
attractive terms which make and there's
been nobody else on the field if you
know in the playoffs next weekend you
had the opportunity to put your football
team out there on the field with no
other team you'd win the game and that's
exactly what's happened over the last 10
years here they have been in the field
on the field all by themselves plan to
do to address that you're gonna put your
money where your mouth is actually
podium just so that you can be seen
better i get oh sorry sorry the question
there is are you going to put resources
into this what do I plan to do it
started a couple of hours ago I got up
in Washington DC to come to the National
Press Club to talk to you about it
and I'm going to keep doing that as long
and as hard as I can Thank You mr. Soros
well I very much the same water yeah I
very much support it is this effort but
frankly I've got so many other causes
that I am engaged in that I'm not making
a sort of a concerted effort like mr.
Gates's but understood of your first
question I am at a loss to understand
why we are debating this issue it is so
obvious that the estate tax is a
valuable attacks we should keep it that
I I really think it's in some ways a
distortion of where the debate has gone
I could just also add the responsible
wealth has begun a process of assembling
resources to do we already have raised
money for this organizing tour that will
be doing in the coming months we're
going to be doing forums around the
country on the estate tax issue and
we're raising money now to do
significant advertising another question
right there Marilyn G max with cops news
my question is for the senator could you
tell us that in detail again where does
this stand in the legislative process
what's likely to happen what's the
timeline in Congress I it's somewhat
hard to predict the timeline as you can
imagine with the new leadership and new
folks in charge of the Sun in the house
but I think we can anticipate that after
the appropriations bills are dealt with
that still remain for last year that
then we will turn our attention to the
president's proposed stimulus package
and then some time after that as we go
through the budget process there will be
an attempt by those who advocate the
repeal of the estate tax to make that
part of an overall package of making
previously enacted tax
that's permanent so I would expect we
would see that sometime this spring part
of the stimulus package then asked
Congress deals with it we will it get
folded into that or would you rather
keep this separate I think those who are
pushing the stimulus package will keep
it separate I think they will first have
the stimulus package voted on and then
at some later point have the move to
make permanent tax cuts already enacted
with the estate tax being part of that
package another question right here yes
probably from AFP for mr. gates of the
estate tax is one element in a very big
tax system and now there's a lot of
debate about some other elements of
reform that some say may also change the
balance do you have any plans to expand
or change your focus or you simply
focused on this one element here just me
repeat the question for mr. Gates's
there are other elements of the tax
system he's been primarily outspoken on
the issue of the estate tax does he have
a position on some of these other tax
proposals questions on presidents or any
of the other proposed
thank you thank you um i'm not i'm not
an expert on things like stimulus and
that kind of thing so i really don't
have a view about that I i would just
say i don't i don't believe in all of
the arguments that have been made in
favor of repealing the estate tax that
anybody has had the temerity to suggest
that it's some sort of an economic
stimulus that were involved in here this
is this is simply a matter of
eliminating tax that rich people don't
want to pay it that we're not talking
about economic stimulus at all so it
doesn't fit in with that that discussion
in any way any position on any of the
other i mean Vern if you want to say do
you want to never see you don't want to
talk comment on it okay well I I just
don't feel confident to comp to comment
on on the stimulus package I don't I
just frankly don't understand those
things I will confess to a high degree
of alarm of looking at senator Conrad's
charts the question yes sir yeah I can't
move her american city business
journal's this a question for Senator
Conrad it's kind of a follow-up to the
other question assuming a stimulus
package does get passed through does
that make it less likely that you know
after they take however many hundreds of
billions of dollars out of the Treasury
future Treasury that they'll be able to
come back and take hundreds of billions
of dollars more the Treasury it seems
like that would make it a little harder
for them to have the tax cuts permanent
I think it does you ask an excellent
question the gentleman is asking if you
pass the stimulus package which the full
cost of that by the way is over nine
hundred billion dollars they've said the
stimulus packages some 670 billion of
costs but they have not included the
associated interest costs when you add
in the interest costs the cost of this
stimulus package is over nine hundred
billion dollars you stack on top of that
making permanent the tax the taxes
already reduced if you make those
permanent that has a
this decade of about another six hundred
billion dollars next decade that has a
cost of four trillion dollars now none
of this adds up now none of it adds up
now before these additional proposals
we're already in deficit we're already
on course to seeing the national debt
climb from it's already high levels so I
think sober reflection would lead one to
conclude if another round of tax
reduction has passed still another one
beyond that becomes even more
indefensible remember that in 2001 we
passed a package that with interest
costs 1.7 trillion dollars the rationale
then the president said well I'm only
giving back one out of every four
dollars of projected surplus now there
is no projected surplus that rationale
has evaporated so it's very hard to see
the justification for additional tax
reductions that will have to be with
borrowed money it's like you take out
your credit card and you feel good about
paying off your other credit card when
you just transfer the debt from one to
the other most people would say you've
made no progress there you're just
shuffling the deck and you're shuffling
the debt and that's exactly what's going
on here some have said well we went
through this before in the 1980s and it
didn't do any great harm well the 1980s
are fundamentally different and they're
different because then we had time to
get well this time there is no time to
get well because the baby boomers are
born there live today they're gonna
going to retire they are eligible for
Social Security and Medicare and the
numbers don't lie we are headed in a
future administration in a future
Congress for the most difficult
decisions ever faced by the people of
the United States with respect to their
fiscal condition
and the fundamental question is do we
dig the hole deeper or do we start
filling it in other questions yes please
maybe let me comment on the stimulus
just I think that the stimulus program
is actually a misnomer we do need
stimulus but it has to be short term and
a temporary and having these long-term
tax concessions that basically benefit
the top the rich is actually going to
hinder the recovery right now we do need
it we can absorb it because there are
two resources interest rates will not be
greatly affected while we are in a
recession at the moment we come out of
the recession that we will have much
higher interest rates because of the
looming budget deficit there is one
similarity with the 80s because in the
80s we had very high interest rates
maybe I could just add one point just to
to buttress the point mr. Soros is made
because I'm in complete agreement with
him I think the only justification one
can have for adding to this deficit and
debt is to stimulate give lift of the
economy in a period of weakness the
president's plan some 900 billion
dollars of cost they have now
acknowledged less than 60 billion of
that is at the time of economic weakness
only about 60 billion dollars of that
cost would be this year the rest of the
cost is at a time when they are
projecting strong economic growth this
is this is the thing that is most hard
to understand they're promoting what
they call a growth package most of the
cost of which will occur when they
themselves are already projecting
strong economic growth that is the years
after this one the actual stimulus is a
tiny part of this package I think one
could justify a more robust package now
to give lift to the economy but do it in
a way that as mr. Soros is described is
temporary and interestingly enough on a
bipartisan basis last year those of us
most responsible for the budget on a
bipartisan basis that is the chairman
and ranking member of the House and
Senate budget committees agreed on a set
of principles to apply to any stimulus
and in that set of principles was the
one just described my mr. Soros that is
that it be temporary in nature but it
not have an adverse effect on our
long-term budget condition that is
already so seriously burdened yes Erika
Russell Mulcahy little portable crime
reporter I mean this state's tax repeal
is being pursued by the heirs of the
gala wine and Mars candy fortune among
others I'm wondering you two gentlemen
mr. gates mr. Soros in your interaction
with other wealthy people are they
coming up to us and saying what the heck
are you guys doing here leave us alone
and if you give us some sense about your
interaction with other people who oppose
your view the question is some of the
big backers of the repeal effort include
the gala wine and the Mars candy family
some of the very wealthy families in
their interactions with other wealthy
individuals are people what what is
what's the nature of those conversations
very brief very briefly I don't have any
interaction with the gallo and mosfet
rivets or any others no I I I guess I'm
the circles that I move in I basically
feel support rather than disapproval
that is not to say that I haven't had
some rich people's say exactly as you
say but what the hell are you doing my
response exactly the same as mr. Soros
people don't tend to come up to you and
pick a fight with you about these things
so I have no doubt among my friends
there are those who would would like to
do so but are too polite but on the
other hand I actually have been
astonished and I very very pleased to
see the number of people who who are as
state taxpayers who who say to me that
is really the right thing to do and of
course when you look at a list that
includes people like Warren Buffett you
know you it does have some credibility
what what do you think the political
impact was when the think tanks created
the name the death tax and started
pushing this as the death tax instead of
the estate tax question is what was the
political impact when conservative think
tanks created the death tax name what
effect did that have on this debate it
was effective it was effective it
created an impression which is false but
effective I would just add that we are
doing a lot of recruiting among wide
sectors but for one example is the
chairman of Bloomberg is convening a
lunch later in the week for mr. gates
where a number of prominent CEOs from
around the country will be there and we
will be in listing them in this effort
and as well to speak out yeah one more
question for mr. gates can you say is
there a certain amount of agreement or
discord within your own family
on this issue comment is there the
question for mr. gates is their discord
or agreement within your own family on
this matter I know that my son agrees
with me I'm not quite so sure about my
daughter's I there they're going along
they're polite to their father and I
think maybe they agree with me but ice I
sense some misgivings on their part in
terms of the impact on their own
physical welfare question right there
Allen Washington independent writers of
do you all think there are going to be
real consequences to the growing gap
between rich and poor in the United
States and you think you all have given
more thought to this and more concern to
this than george w bush has the question
is are there serious consequences to a
growing gap between rich and poor and
have you given more thought to the
potential implications of that growing
disparity than the president
no people people comment that this
enormous disparity is something which
has happened in the presence of an
estate tax so what what are you arguing
about here it's happening even though
there is an estate tax the answer to
which is that all of that enormous
wealth which has become concentrated in
that in the wealthiest one percent of
our population has occurred without any
very significant part of those people
dying and paying estate taxes which is
which is why I think it is so important
for us to understand exactly the kind of
charts that Senator Conrad is showing us
that the impact for the future that that
the estate tax will generate large sums
of money that it will accordingly on the
other hand minimize the potentially
enormous growth in inherited wealth I I
been around a while and i have watched
and I I have what may seem like a naive
impression but i think that people with
money have more power in this country
than other people do and i think that
that money is staying in one family
generations in row is enormously
unhealthy i don't think it's in the
interest of this country to have wealth
concentrated as it is and and as the
quote that mr. Collins gave us the most
especially worst part of it is that it
stays in the same family that we have
this potential for a serious and
powerful aristocracy which I think we
should avoid and the estate tax will
help do that I think most most of the
wealth in America is in the hands of
people or that created it or at least
one that is the impression that people
have and therefore they are much they
they approve or there isn't that degree
of disapproval as there is in other
countries where most of the wealth is
inherited we have a very healthy
democracy and we should keep it healthy
and the estate tax will help us do so if
you look abroad you see many countries
with an inherited wealth wealthy class
and dispossessed and you see revolutions
and upheavals and bad government very
often dictatorships supporting the
wealthy and so on so this is we have it
very good in America and let's keep it
that way time for one or maybe two more
questions yeah i'm jessica rose guards
from CNN I guess this question is for
Senator Conrad as mr. gates pointed out
people with money tend to have power and
no offense to Senator but isn't that why
we're having this debate if the people
with money are the ones with power they
have more influence so how do you plan
to get around that when this debate
comes up well the great thing about our
country is this is a democracy and
everybody has a voice and everybody has
an ability to influence the outcome and
certainly those with wealth have a
greater ability to influence the outcome
because they can make large campaign
contributions but i still believe we
have a chance to win based on the merits
and as people understand that a death
tax the label death tax is fundamentally
a fraud there's no death tax in America
there's an attacks on estates and if you
don't as an individual at least have a
million dollars or if you're a couple if
you don't have two million dollars you
pay zero and already in the law that is
going
be increased to three and a half million
dollars by 2009 for an individual seven
million dollars for a couple if you
don't have as a couple seven million
dollars in 2009 you pay nothing zero and
the fundamental argument that this is to
avoid double taxation flies in the face
of this new information that in a states
of 10 million dollars and more fifty-six
percent of the assets have never been
subjected to taxation because they have
unrealized capital gains facts matter
words matter and as Bill Gates indicated
the other side has been out on the field
running up and down the field with
nobody out there to tackle nobody else
to nobody out there to call them to
account nobody out there to say to them
we're headed we're already in deficit
we're already building debt that is
going to dramatically increase in the
years ahead as the baby boomers retire
how these bills going to be paid and how
can you justify those of you who
advocate repeal of the estate tax how
can you justify shifting this burden off
of the three tenths of one percent of a
state's they're going to pay it on to
all the rest of the people when there
are already incredible burdens facing
them the burden of Social Security the
burden of Medicare national defense
Homeland Security and all the rest this
is a question about choices and I
believe when the American people have
the full facts before them they'll make
a very clear choice the polls already
show it if you just ask them you want to
eliminate the estate tax they say yes if
you say to them but if you do that you
deepen the deficits in the debt all the
money is coming out of Social Security
in fact the cost of repealing the estate
tax that cost is enough money to solve
half
of the shortfall in Social Security that
amount of money solves half of the
shortfall and Social Security when
people are presented with those facts
and those choices they make a completely
different determination then they are
opposed to a repeal of the estate tax
and support reform of the estate tax
support increasing the amount of money
exempt and doing it now rather than
repealing the estate tax completely I
want to call on bill gayle from
Brookings Institution also comment
thanks I just want to make one quick
factual statement about the question
about the death tax not only is it a
misnomer for all the reasons that were
already mentioned but in fact
ninety-eight percent of people that die
get a subsidy via the estate tax rules
rather than a tax and that's because not
only do they not owe taxes but the the
basis of the capital gains that they owe
get stepped up so what happens if
somebody bought a stock for ten dollars
and when they die it's worth a hundred
dollars if they had sold it the day
before they died they would have to pay
taxes on that $90 capital gain but if
they died holding that asset the person
that inherits that asset gets it with a
100 dollar basis so that if that person
then sold that they would they would not
have to pay any tax on the one hundred
dollar sale so there's actually a death
subsidy for ninety eight percent of
people who died and then there's the
estate tax for the other two percent
we're at the end of our time and I want
to thank our guests and thank you for
coming if some of you are interested i
think i'm not sure but that there are
individual slots for interviews
scheduled